es una función exponencial eso es muy
importante así que lo voy a subrayar con
este color con un valor inicial de menos
2 eso también es muy importante así que
lo voy a subrayar con este otro color y
con una razón común de un séptimo eso
también es importante y lo voy a
subrayar con este otro color dice
escribe
la fórmula dgt ok y como sabemos que je
t'aime es una función exponencial
entonces gente que te va a ser de la
forma o se va a ver de la siguiente
manera va a ser igual a un valor inicial
que le vamos a poner el nombre de amd
que multiplican a una razón común que le
vamos a poner el nombre de r esto
elevado a la potencia de esto elevado a
la potencia tema pero nosotros ya
sabemos cuánto vale el valor inicial el
valor inicial vale menos dos así que am
podemos sustituir por menos dos y
también sabemos cuánto vale la razón
común la razón común vale un séptimo así
que en lugar de r podemos poner un
séptimo y ya está vamos a reescribir
esto para que se vea mucho más limpio y
ordenado gtt sería de la siguiente forma
dtm se vería de la siguiente manera me
va a quedar como menos dos menos dos que
es mi valor inicial que multiplica a
nuestra razón común que sabemos que es
un séptimo sabemos que es un séptimo
esto elevado a la potencia t así que
déjenme ponerlos y esto está elevado a
la potencia t y ojalá esta idea tenga
sentido para ti el valor inicial es este
el número que tenemos aquí ya que es el
número que vamos a encontrar cuando el
tiempo vale cero si el tiempo vale cero
entonces me quedaría un séptimo elevado
a la potencia cero pero sabemos que eso
es lo mismo que uno entonces g de cero
nuestro valor inicial va a ser igual a
menos dos por uno lo cual es menos 2 ese
sería nuestro valor inicial y luego si
lo piensas cada vez que incrementa a t
en 1 vamos a multiplicar por un séptimo
una vez más entonces la razón entre dos
términos
consecutivos serán un séptimo y es por
eso que lo llamamos la razón común ojalá
que hayas encontrado esto muy
interesante